[Musique]
ce sont près de 400 participants
professionnels qui se sont réunis pour
l'ouverture des rencontres territoriales
de la protection de l'enfance en
outre-mer ce mercredi 30 novembre une
quatrième édition qui se tient pour la
première fois à la Réunion un événement
animé par idéal Co et co-organisé par le
département
nous voyons depuis quelques temps de ta
mort depuis la crise sanitaire qui est à
la covid-19 des situations se dégradent
et c'est pour cela que nous avons en
charge d'aller encore plus loin de mieux
coordonner nos politiques publiques nous
le faisons à travers l'Observatoire de
la protection de l'enfance et nous le
faisons aussi à travers la tenue ici de
ce comité
interdom de façon justement à mieux
travailler ensemble
poids donner de la cohérence à nos
politiques en matière d'accompagnement
des enfants les plus fragiles
la collectivité départementale a pour
responsabilité l'accompagnement des
enfants relevant de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance qui sont près de 2500 à la
réunion nous le faisons à travers nos
services dédiés notamment ceux
concernant les informations
préoccupantes nous le faisons aussi à
travers le réseau d'accueil notamment
les familles d'accueil
rémunéré par le département
pour justement accompagner une large
partie de ces infos de ces enfants nous
le faisons aussi à travers des
structures d'accueil et parfois en
sollicitant des tiers dignes de
confiance
la responsabilité c'est bien évidemment
la détection de ces informations
c'est aussi la mise en oeuvre de
certains nombre de mesures de protection
en lien bien évidemment avec les
partenaires notamment les autorités
judiciaires
et lorsque cela savait nécessaire donc
il y a des solutions d'hébergement et
donc d'accompagnement à mettre en oeuvre
c'est ce que nous faisons
prévu sur deux jours ces rencontres
comprennent cette séance plénière et 4
ateliers pour permettre aux
professionnels d'innover autour des
enjeux multiples de la protection de
l'enfance
[Musique]